I didn't realize that a lot of things I
was doing whether it was sleeping in or
validating or making excuses they were
hurting my confidence and if you don't
have confidence you're always gonna find
a way to lose an entrepreneurship trying
to do everything yourself
I promise we'll leave you dead broke and
stressed and with massive regret you
have to step up now not next week not
next month now this is the greatest time
in human history to build a life in
business on your terms I'll tell you
everything's changing in this new
economy and we'll worked five or ten
years ago doesn't work anymore I think
the most valuable currency there is
right now is the effect you have on
someone else and I want to shout out
Evan Carmichael for the impact is making
for the millions of people that he's
really touching it's very admirable and
inspiring need motivation watch a top
ten of belief nation what's up at seven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who started
his entrepreneurial career at age 15 to
becoming broke and discouraged at age 22
to becoming a best-selling author and
worth seven figures by age 27 he's Peter
vu and here's my take on his top ten
rules success joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
get clear step one you have to get
crystal clear and get rid of all the
noise in your head of exactly where you
want to go what industry you got to get
clear on who you are who you're not who
you want to become and who you need on
your team to get to the next level
I obviously can't deep dive I don't want
to spend 45 minutes on this video I'm
gonna give you the simplistic version
you guys can obviously check it out in
my book or just take what you need from
each tip to make sure you get clarity so
figure out your ideal outcome in the
next six months how much money will you
be making how much do you want saved
what does your team look like what
twenty percent of activities will be
yielding 80% of your results so number
one is get crystal clear and I knew two
things I couldn't stand being broke I
was so sick of struggling and two I
never wanted to work for anybody that's
the two things I knew so I got clear
that I never wanted to live like I was
living ever again rule number two build
your confidence
everyone has what's inside them called a
confidence accounts and here's the scary
thing at every moment you're either
helping or you're hurting your
confidence there's no in-between every
decision you make is either helping the
account or hurting it and every
accomplishment and everything you've
done up to this point is because of that
account so I didn't realize that a lot
of things I was doing whether it was
sleeping in or validating or making
excuses they were hurting my confidence
and if you don't have confidence you're
always gonna find a way to lose in
entrepreneurship so you always got to
understand how important confidence is
and protect it at the highest level and
how do you build confidence
well confidence is just certainty right
what's the number one reason people
won't leave corporate to go to
entrepreneurship they're scared because
they have what at their other job they
have certainty it's like well the
paychecks coming in this new economy the
only certainty you have is the
confidence in yourself and your ability
to make it happen so you have to create
certainty for your life and business by
doing your due diligence by studying by
reaching out to high level people and by
making sure that you have an eye
that whatever you say your actions
follow because when you get results
that's the often an alternate confidence
booster you know what I mean rule number
three shift your circle of influence you
get clear you build your confidence then
step three is shift your circle of
influence make a list of the five people
in your industry that are already
dominating and building the lifestyle or
maybe they've already built the
lifestyle that you want to emulate or be
like study them reach out get them as
mentors increase the time with your
growth friends and get rid of those
people that are toxic around you that
don't believe in you or don't make you
feel exceptional so I made a list of the
top 5 people I reached out to them and I
so I thought about who I was associated
with and how they were affecting my
standards and my vision and my goals and
I lowered my time that I spent with
maintenance friends and I hired the time
I spent with growth friends that
challenged me that held me to higher
standards because you're either hanging
out with people who let you off the hook
or who hold you accountable and based on
who you associate with
that's who you become so that's step
three is shift your circle of influence
and you're gonna cut your learning curve
in half people always say yeah but I
don't know how to get the six figures
it's hard to do in six months you don't
have to figure it out your mentors your
higher level circle of influence will
tell you exactly what to do so you can
follow their lead and cut your learning
curve in half trying to do everything
yourself
I promise we'll leave you dead broke and
stressed and with massive regret so
don't do that rule number four live your
life to the fullest and the LAX soon had
Europe's getting away traveling trying
to see the world and really maximize
every experience I can because I see too
many people that get stuck in the rat
race they get stuck and doing the same
thing over and over again without
thinking about how quick time passes if
you're not intentional with how you
spend it and with understanding the
importance of variety and getting out
and seeing the world I wanted to share
my experience with you and show you the
footage inspire you
and challenge you to travel more take a
mini vacation every couple weeks if you
can't afford it like at one point I
couldn't afford it I was broke that
should fire you up to find a way to
increase your finances to make money you
want all the hunger you can have when
you're building a better life so use
that as hunger to go to the next level
you want to protect your lifestyle
because there's two very important
things that keep fulfillment its
maximizing memorable and exciting
experiences and number two working on
things that juice you up that inspire
you that gets you excited about life and
when your feet hit the ground in the
morning you're pumped to get up and take
on your day and working on things that
matter does that to you and traveling
sparks your creativity it sparks your
juices and make sure you're more
creative and it expands your awareness
of what you think and what your
philosophy is about the world rule
number five my personal favorite create
good rituals inspirations really short
term and doesn't really last pass the
activity producing it habits are what
drive people's action I go to seminars
and I mean I've spent a lot of money on
personal development because you want to
invest back in yourself and if you go to
seminars people spend like two three
five ten grand and literally five
percent of them if you catch them two
weeks later are the exact same person
because they get inspired but they don't
put it into execution and what happens
is they go back to who they were so what
I would tell people is make sure you
have a daily routine that sets you up
for success so one my prizefighter
routine a morning routine that sets you
up for success first of all there's a
lot of stuff on morning routines that's
that's fine to have like a bunch of
morning routine stuff but I'm all about
outcomes so the whole purpose of a
morning routine is two things to get you
in a better state of mind to get you
confident and courageous to take on the
day and to to have intention and to know
exactly what you're doing that day so if
you just have a rituals and here's
what's cool every frustration or every
the kind of failure is because there's
no rituals or systems in place right so
you got to have systems for each area of
your life so for mindset you gotta have
a ritual every week for productivity you
gotta have a ritual every week so let me
give you an example so if you want a
mindset ritual you have to have
non-negotiables in your schedule that
you do no matter what no matter how you
feel you start making decisions based
off standards and values not emotions or
feelings rule number six hustle
show me somebody who's making millions
that didn't put in the work show me
somebody living life on their terms that
doesn't respect the hustle you're not
gonna find anybody stop putting in the
world owes you something it owes you
nothing and for those still thinking
they're entitled to something without
hard work please sit down and let the
real hustlers earn their spot you owe
the world contribution and value because
you're living in it don't waste space
they say numbers don't lie but neither
does the cry grind knows if you've been
hustling the grind knows if you've been
cutting corners and the grind knows if
you've been putting in the work how do
know if you've been really on the grind
you check your results and if you don't
have the results you want it's time to
get real with yourself you're either
cutting corners when nobody's watching
you aren't staying consistent or your
time hasn't come yet and you need to
keep hustling it's that simple if you
want to really get the most out of the
grind you have to do the hardest thing
first you need to seize each day but
make sure you define what your highest
value activities are and do that the
first thing whether you feel like it or
not when your feet hit the ground in the
morning you need to be thinking the
world isn't ready for me and then don't
stop when you feel like it's not when
you're finished champions don't feelings
make them weak incompletion gives them
power and confidence when you stay in
the grind you need to focus on being in
your own reality the reality where you
compare yourself to you in the reality
where your only competition is the
person in the mirror rule number seven
step up now and I keep coming to the
realization that you're not getting any
younger your parents are getting older
you have to step up now not next week
not next month now this is the greatest
time in human history to build a life
and business on your terms but you have
to dedicate yourself but what industry
you want to go all-in on you have to
make sure you define your values you
have to make sure you define your
strengths and find an industry where
your gifts will make room for you and
you're gonna get paid based off what
you're worth I can't do that for you you
have to find that it's on you the more
you need someone else to motivate you
the less money you're gonna make
and the more frustrated you be the more
you could spark your own fire motivate
yourself the better lifestyle you're
gonna have rule number 8 improve your
productivity I think there's different
definitions of productivity I mean I
think there's if you talk to 10
entrepreneurs there's probably going to
be 10 different definitions right I
think productivity is a couple things
one it's a productive life that
focused on and committed to producing
and progressing towards your ideal
vision and I also think it's the use of
your time energy intelligence and
resources in a manner calculated to move
you closer to meaningful goals and
productivity isn't just results in
getting things done it's about creating
free time for your family doing what you
want and having 100% control over your
future I don't think it's about doing
more faster it's about doing the right
things deliberately so the first
question I'd ask is what are your
biggest productivity killers like what
are the things that have killed your
productivity in the past because if you
don't become aware we have to start with
a ground level here if you don't become
aware of where you're wasting time that
will always come up month after month
year after year
so it can be distractions as far as
social media it can be um internet
sometimes it can be sleeping in it could
be people interrupting you all the time
right it can be lack of planning maybe
it's your environment but I challenge
people what are three to five
productivity Killers that have been
hurting you in the last let's say six
months and I think when you do that I
think multitasking is one I think
notifications on the phone is one but I
challenge people what three are costing
you the most rule number nine raise your
standards you get always in life exactly
what you tolerate if you tolerate being
disrespected
you'll always be disrespected if you
tolerate being overweight and out of
energy you will always be out of energy
tired and overweight if you tolerate
being overworked and underpaid you will
always be overworked and underpaid so
the standards you set for yourself
determine your life and your future
people are expecting all these amazing
results they're expecting a level 10
life but they have level 4 standards and
habits it's in congruent not only is it
gonna stress you out but you will not
get to where you want to go okay so
here's the reality you have to define
what your standards are that you
wanna race pick two or three areas of
your life that you want to be improved
on maybe it's health
maybe it's income maybe it's
relationships I don't know but what are
you currently tolerating that isn't
serving you well that's the first step
is raise your standards when you say
your standards are raised that's when
they're raised when you stop tolerating
disrespect that's when it will stop and
what I was saying is people are
expecting different results by taking
the same action and as you know that's
called insanity and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips go all in on your vision tires now
what are you waiting for get me
permission you'll need other people to
tell you that you got to go all there
it's all on you now is the time for you
to make up for all the times in your
life where you didn't give your all when
you made excuses when you cut Clips the
new you happens now
time to stop being like most people it's
time to stop letting other people
dictate your standards in your vision
most people say they're gonna have a
brand new van when the new year starts
when January comes they're in the gym
they're fired up if you are the gym on
the beginning of the year you're gonna
see it stacked with people everywhere no
two weeks later you'll see nobody it's
because people get pumped and hyped but
they don't follow through once the
actions bit tougher it's on you it's
your turn to spark your own fire you
don't need someone else to tell you to
spark be on fire to tell you what you're
worth what's on you and the new you
begins when you make a decision to go
all-in on what you think about every day
under vision and make it a reality
I'll tell you everything's changing in
this new economy and we'll work to five
or ten years ago doesn't work anymore I
think the most valuable currency there
is right now is the effect you have on
someone else and I want to shout out
Evan Carmichael for the impact he's
making for the millions of people that
he's really touching it's very admirable
and inspiring and I want to thank you
for that now here's the deal I was gonna
make this perfect video with a great
background have my camera crew come out
but I just want to drop the need to be
perfect to be authentic I'm shooting
this with my iPhone right now and
there's a bunch of noise in the
background but you have to give up the
need to be liked by everyone to be
perfect just to be yourself and to be
authentic so I want to thank you for
watching this video and Evan thank you
for shifting this culture and pushing
this culture forward with your content
with your inspiration with your wisdom
and innovation man I appreciate you and
I have the utmost respect for you your
brand and your legacy and I've been
obsessed with entrepreneurship and
obsessed with helping entrepreneurs
leaders sales professionals CEOs live a
life in a business on their terms
because here's the deal you could build
a hundred million dollar business but if
you don't have a lifestyle that you're
inspired by that you're proud of you did
it all wrong so I want to thank you for
watching I want to thank to you guys
for leading the majority not being the
majority and for investing in yourself
and for really sharpening your mind
because that's what it's gonna take the
change this game each and every one of
you really stepping up and investing in
yourself and telling yourself right now
matters so thanks again evan much
respect see you guys soon
now I've got three very special bonus
cups from Peter on how to master
yourself maximize your energy and
consistently learn and grow but before
that I want to get to you what point
resonated the most with you in this
video
don't just watch another video make a
commitment to change in your life or
business somehow what are you going to
commit to changing leave it down the
comments below
when you write it down you're much more
likely to follow through put it down
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clips
you have to learn how to master yourself
and know how to spark your own fire the
more you have to count on someone else
to motivate you the less money you'll
make and less effective you'll be so
learn how to master yourself how to
spark your own fire and how I did that
was I put my plan I put my vision I put
my values and my reasons and my goals on
one page who this and I like literally
even I have this is from 2015 page yeah
but I have like five or six of them and
I redo every couple months but it's like
I've done this since 2012 I had it in
the shower above the shower it's
laminated but let me tell you what's on
that page because it's such a
game-changer for me um first is your
ideal outcome a lot of people don't even
know their ideal outcome of what they
want what they want to accomplish in the
next six months like if I ask a hundred
entrepreneurs hey what is the ideal
outcome for you and your business like
how many hours are you working how much
money are you bringing in what's your
subscribers look like how involved are
you in the business right how big is
your team what exactly are your
marketing tactics they're like I have no
idea
ninety-nine out of a hundred don't know
so what's your ideal outcome and don't
base this off your past or limitations
base this off what's possible in your
potential right so just a simple
paragraph what's your ideal outcome I
don't really like this a vision
statement because that's over over
talked about overplayed but I like to
tell people it's your ideal outcome so
once you have that on top then this is
big your core values like what are most
important to you in life in business
because you want to build a business
around your values not settle for a
business that doesn't match your values
because then you're living in
congruently right and people do this all
the time but in the new economy in 2017
there's no reason why you can't create
and design your ideal lifestyle or be
picky and choosey with your business
because you're becoming so valuable so
values for me it's family freedom
autonomy and then legacy an impact even
before income people always say well
what about income it's like yeah that's
very important to me but I have leverage
where I don't need income so what's cool
for me is
my values are intact to where I can say
yes and no to any opportunity that comes
to me based on my values like I've
turned down speeches Evan for close to
ten grand one was in Chicago in January
that's enough to turn anything down in
Chicago because it's freezing I'm sorry
at all the Chicago people you probably
agree but anyways I turn down speeches
that are well paid and I've done three
speeches in the inner city in LA for
underprivileged kids now if my values
were number one money I'd probably turn
down the free speeches and do all the
paid ones but my values impacting giving
back so you gotta define what your
values are after that it's your top five
goals so what are the big five for the
next six months and I'll kind of run
through this kind of quick but what are
the five things that you want to
accomplish and get done in the next six
months and then underneath that it's
your most powerful reasons what are the
reasons that drive you what are your top
five most compelling reasons because
this is the fuel that gets you to take
action on the top five right so what are
your five biggest reasons you might have
to write down like 20 or 30 and simplify
to get to the ones that mean something
but if you don't have if you're not
waking up at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning
fired up and excited your reasons aren't
strong enough I'm serious so get some
strong reasons of why you want to do
what you do and lastly what's your one
key skill or one key habit that's most
relevant to your six-month vision that
you're gonna focus on for the next month
or two until it's mastered you see one
big part of productivity Evan is
focusing on mastery versus overload
there's so much information there's all
this technology there's podcasts YouTube
audios videos books training seminars
and a lot of entrepreneurs use it as a
cop-out to where they're like I want to
keep learning and growing and instead of
executing on what they already know they
want to learn more and say well I'm
still studying gonna know you need to
execute and get addicted to outcomes not
just information so now you measure
everything you're studying against this
one-page productivity plan and if you do
that it gives you so much clarity now
the goal is to let your vision guide you
not your current circumstances here's a
big advantage in entrepreneurship
maximizing what you put in your body
your energy okay how your emotions are
running emotional intelligence
I can't I'm not going to
of a thousand tips right now watch what
you put in your body and make sure you
realize that nothing tastes as good as
health feels you're supposed to eat to
be vibrant and feel healthy so if you're
eating healthy and you're eating greens
and you're drinking a lot of water and
you're just watching what you're putting
in your body you're gonna feel a lot
more alive be more resourceful and feel
like you're more intelligent when making
decisions
lastly the game-changing consistent
growth and learning to where you're
always trying to improve and you're
always reaching for new heights
challenging yourself to reach the next
level getting around people that think
bigger and I'm gonna be vulnerable I'm
gonna be very blunt here I was 23 I had
a hundred and seventy 180 grand saved I
was thinking I was on top of the world
but then I hired a mentor that made his
first million when he was 21 and he said
Peter that's not much money why you so
pumped up you can't even buy a piece of
property in cash that's not much what
are you doing and I said Jesus that
totally raised my standards I would have
probably got complacent and let up but
he came in and said that's not much
money saved yes you're 23 I had seven
figures when I was your age so it
challenged me to think bigger and I
realized a couple years later it's not
at all about the money it's about the
impact the influence the lifestyle
building life on your terms but you have
to have people that raise your standards
so continue to grow continue to invest
your income in four different things
back into yourself because there's
nothing more important than investing in
you back in your business back in assets
that make money work for you
multifamily rental properties angel
investing things like that and then
memorable experiences because when
you're doing experiences and creating
them that are memorable you get more
inspired raise your standard Apple at
the core is core values
is that even that people with passion
can change the way people now one drop
of my self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me i don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or absolutely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details